welcome back to cbs this morning in our
road to a vaccine series we look at a
crucial issue
for the first coronavirus vaccines this
morning pfizer said it is applying
and will apply today for fda
authorization and emergency youth
authorization what's called for its
vaccine
now the drug giant hopes to produce up
to 50 million doses
this year with about half of those doses
going here to the u.s
moderna will apply soon to the fda and
expects to deliver about 20 million
doses in the u.s by the end of the year
companies are trying to figure out now
what the best way is to keep the
products safe and effective
and as our dana jacobs is about to show
us it is an icy challenge dana good
morning
to you tell us about it all right tony
good morning it is a challenge because
hours after that coveted vaccine gets
fda approval a series of
tightly choreographed logistics will
start playing out to get the vaccine
into people's arms now both moderna and
pfizer's vaccines require two doses
weeks apart
and then to further complicate things
there are obstacles to moving
and storing the vaccine
at acme dry ice in cambridge
massachusetts these are big pellets
and these are small pellets owner mark
savannah and his team
are working around the clock to provide
dry ice to vaccine manufacturers
not something i'm guessing that when you
start a dry ice company you think about
no i never thought i'd be saving lives
but it feels really good
colder than antarctica in winter dry ice
is critical to transporting and storing
the coronavirus vaccines
the demand is definitely higher right
now for the vaccine
makers because as fast as they're making
the vaccine they're shipping it out
dry ice is made from carbon dioxide or
co2
a byproduct of ethanol production with
americans driving less in the wake of
the pandemic ethanol plants shut down
resulting in a shortage of carbon
dioxide over the summer
how important is the co2 to the dry ice
process if that's the basic ingredient
well without co2
it's like being a mcdonald's without
hamburgers
so this summer there was a shortage of
dry ice what about
right now where there seems to be so
much focus right now we happen to have a
great supply chain of co2
you know it's always scary to see what
the demand is going to be with the
vaccine
with the help of dry ice vaccines will
be shipped from manufacturing facilities
to freezer farms like pfizers in
kalamazoo michigan
and then to vaccination sites across the
country
tanya alcorn is a pfizer supply chain
executive
what's your biggest challenge as far as
distribution honestly the biggest
challenge is we're doing
so much in parallel we don't have all
the answers pfizer's vaccine needs to be
kept at about
94 degrees below zero fahrenheit
so it developed a thermal shipper to
transport and store its vaccine
at sub-arctic temperatures so the cool
box at least we think it's cool is um
it's a shipper box about the size of
like a carry-on suitcase and then
there's dry ice that goes around it and
then it has
actually a device within it that has a
continuous
gps and temperature monitor so we will
be able to have
continuous eyes on every shipper each
cool box contains a minimum
of about a thousand vaccine doses that's
a problem
tim size represents 43 rural hospitals
across wisconsin if you can ship a
thousand you can you can ship
200 it's more expensive it's more
cumbersome size says the
nearly 1 000 minimum dose requirement is
a challenge for rural areas
it means rural health care workers may
have to travel to big cities to receive
the vaccine
all while tackling a new wave of
coronavirus infections
we're under a huge surge so for them to
have to travel maybe take a day off
of work to travel to a regional center
to then stand in line to get vaccinated
go back to work and two weeks later go
back taking another day off
it just makes the logistics really bad
pfizer says they are working on a
smaller shipper with less doses
which should be available early next
year ultra cold freezers
can help vaccine doses survive longer
but
size says those are out of reach
financially for most rural hospitals
there's a lot of other things they could
do with 15 or 20 thousand dollars
moderna
says its vaccine is stable at standard
refrigeration temperatures and can be
handled using existing
infrastructure at pharmacies and doctors
offices
psy says that could be a game changer
but he wants
rural areas to have equal access to all
the vaccines
we have a tremendous need to bridge
rural and urban back together
in our country if basically rural is
getting the message we'll start with
urban even if it's for
reasonable logistical reasons it's bad
optics
i don't think anybody wants to give a
message that rural wisconsin rural
america's second class
pfizer told us one of its fundamental
principles is equitable access to their
vaccines for all communities
elkhorn acknowledged that they don't
have all the answers today
but she said pfizer is working with
operation warp speed to make sure
it can get doses out to rural
communities anthony dana thank you wow
this is just so critical what's
happening
this is a critical inflection point in
all of this yeah getting it out and you
want to make sure those front line
medical workers and rural communities
can get this
if you feel like you can solve this
rural issue yeah put the vaccines on a
truck if you have to with more dry ice
get them out to the communities who need
them so the people
in those hospitals who are working so
hard don't have to make the trip
themselves
well what i like is that mark is on the
case he's the ice man
the dry ice man taking it very seriously
and we need him right now yeah